where did you guys find steve at
steve kyle actually found steve he uh
he was like just like i think he was
chugging just like bottles or something
and he had like 500 followers on
instagram or something like that just
chugging [ __ ]
just chugging [ __ ] and kyle's like no
trust me this guy's gonna be [ __ ]
dope so we
bring him down to la and it was like
crazy like
that was like that was like a first like
damn like we have some power to like
like we should be a management company
like we can
like we should be signing people because
it was like
he had 500 followers and then i think
it's like a month in la and he like
his youtube channel had a million
subscribers it was like crazy [ __ ]
just took him to all the parties took
him all these things like people
couldn't help but to like put him in his
videos because it was so
next level what he was doing you know
like
we were talking about that yesterday was
that something you guys are going to
start to do is like
you know you guys are you were talking
yesterday kind of playing around with
the idea maybe doing a record label or
you know you guys do have the power to
blow up an artist and
you know i've seen it so like you feel
like you might be leaving money on the
table by not
doing more 100 i think that's like
the like that's why we're slowly
building like even a bigger team but
like
[ __ ] i say like so much people always
rip on me for that um sorry
the uh basically yeah like there's
there's so many fields i feel like that
we could be growing in
and it's and we're hitting as many as we
can but like
it does feel like right now like there
isn't enough hours in a day to like
really watch everything and monetize
every single category but like
it's it's getting there